parents are upset over the decision by a
Las Vegas Christian School to include
the n-word in several course materials
the school eventually took down a poster
with the derogatory Ward this happened
at Faith Lutheran High School on
Hualapai near Sahara that's where Joshua
peguero Joins us live and Josh what are
you hearing now from parents
well Brian Denise the parents say that
they did speak to the leaders of Faith
Lutheran School to no avail but then the
Las Vegas Alliance of black school
Educators got involved and some action
was taken
the inward no matter where it is used is
a derogatory it's racial abuse and
students should not have to come to a
safe a safe space which is school and
see the n-word used in curricular
materials Camila bywaters is advocating
on behalf of black parents and students
and an email to Faith Lutheran she said
apparents are highly upset that their
voices haven't been heard the issues
include this photo of civil rights
activist Ruby Bridges hung in a
classroom with the n-word written on it
there were also books using that
derogatory term if a black parent comes
to you who has experienced one racism
and has a historical connection to the
trauma and violence of slavery you
should listen to that parrot the
principle of Faith Lutheran sent an
email Tuesday to parents she says it was
agreed that the painting of Ruby Bridges
needed to have context so it was taught
on the importance of it later the
principal additive registrators met with
parents regarding curriculum culture and
hiring practices in most cases the
concerns were addressed I think that
identity is is owed an apology we're
also teaching students who do not have
who do not share the black experience
that it's okay to call you the n-word
now Brian Denise I have yet to receive a
response from Faith Lutheran in regards
to this issue but the principal did tell
parents that it's looking at its English
curriculum to make sure it aligns with
its Christian worldview values and
Mission reporting live on Hualapai and
Sahara Joshua peguero eight news now
now the Las Vegas Alliance of black
school Educators is currently working
with legislators to create a bill that
would limit the teaching of the n-word
in classroom settings